so that's kind of the skeleton of this
proof but maybe you found that
sort of illustration or that logic
unconvincing it was just looking at a
single
or a couple of examples after all so how
do i prove this
uh sort of i guess we would say
exhaustively that's actually the
technical name for this what i'm going
to show you is
proof by exhaustion that's the technical
title for it but does sound
a bit funny it's like i'm just going to
prove it by doing something that makes
me tired
it's also called proof by cases or proof
by case analysis uh what we're going to
try and do
is take an infinite set of possibilities
a could be anything and we're going to
boil it down to
a finite set of cases that cover
all of these infinite possibilities so
hold on to your hats
here's how we're going to prove this
rigorously right
firstly let's actually put the spotlight
on
this number a that we're actually
including
in our expression a cubed minus a and
also
writing it as a minus one a a plus one
product of three
consecutive integers what i can say is
to prove
let's do the let's do the multiple of
two part first right
to prove that a cubed minus a has to be
divisible
by two what i can do is i can consider
all the possibilities
for a when it comes to you know being a
factor sorry a multiple of two whether
it's divisible by two or not
now we actually have a special name for
this it's either it's odd which means
it's not a multiple 2
or it's even which means it is a
multiple of 2. so what i can say is
since a is an integer
a is going to be either
even or odd
so you can see here what i'm doing is
i'm taking all those infinite
possibilities a could be any integer
and i'm boiling it down to a finite set
of cases
even odd there's only two that i need to
worry about
so let's suppose we think about what
happens if a
is even what can that tell us well what
it means is that i can write a
in a particular form i can say well i
could write a
as two times some integer
right where k is
an integer if you wanted you could use
this other notation that we've seen
already let's put it in um i'll put it
in in gray just underneath here
i could say there exists some value of k
such that a is equal to
double that value of k so these two
these two statements here are logically
equivalent i'm just going to go with
this because kind of the way my brain
works right if aza even i can write it
in this particular way so what can i
then say
what does that imply if i can write uh
a as an even number 2k what does that
imply about
a cubed minus a well i can say
a cubed minus a i can write it as this
product of three
consecutive integers a minus one a
a plus one but instead of writing a's
i'm going to substitute them for 2 k's
and see what happens
so if i put in let's have a go 2k minus
1
2k 2k plus 1. now
what i'm trying to prove what i'm
setting out to prove is that
a cubed minus a will be even but that's
quite easy to demonstrate by just taking
out a factor
of two that's what it means for a number
to be even so i'm just going to leave
everything else
in the brackets i've got that 2k minus 1
here
is where i pulled out that 2 from which
i've now put out the front so this just
becomes k
and then i'm left with 2k plus 1. no
matter what value of k
you substitute into here you're going to
get something in here
and then you're going to multiply by 2.
so therefore if a is even
a cubed minus a is also even but of
course a might not be even we're trying
to say a could be any number
so i can say or phase not even
a will be odd now what this implies is
that i have to write a
in a different form i would have to say
a equals 2
k plus 1. i don't have to introduce k
again because i already did it
up the top here so now i want to say if
that is true
if a is odd and it can be written in the
form two k plus one
what does that imply about a cubed
minus a so again i'm going to say a
cubed minus a can be written as the sum
of three consecutive integers but i'm
going to substitute this
uh 2k plus 1 business okay so watch what
happens
here's my 2 k plus 1 minus 1 that's the
number before
2 k plus 1. then there's 2 k plus 1 then
there's the next number 2 k
plus 1 plus 1 again right so you can
see um there's here uh here
and here that i'm making that
substitution for a
but fairly transparently you're going to
get this cancelling of plus 1 and minus
1 out the front so i'm getting
a 2k out the front so in fact i'm going
to write that as 2
and then do a big factorization right so
there's a k
and then i end up with 2 k plus 1 and
then 2
k plus 2 those are the subsequent
numbers so
again i can factorize out this 2 which
means that even if a
is odd i still end up with a cubed minus
a
being an even number so that's really
handy i can now say therefore
for all values of a because i've covered
exhaustively
this is why it's called proof by
exhaustion i've covered all of the cases
there's only two
in this case i've covered the even case
for a covered the odd case so now i can
say
for all values of a that are integers
a cubed minus a is divisible
by 2. so i've handled that part of
things
in order to get to the end i want a
cubed minus a to also be divisible by
3. now how do i go about this i'm also
going to reduce this to cases but
i sort of want to illustrate a little
bit about where my cases come from it's
fairly obvious here when we talk about
oddness
and evenness we deal with these quite
frequently whether a number is odd or
even by the way it's called parity
so because parity comes up so often
that's why we have these names
even and odd we don't have names for
you know you're either divisible by
three or you're not divisible by three
and there are
a few different cases in there that we
need to actually treat so
here's the way we're going to do this we
are now going to i'm going to use a
different color to show my logic is
going in a different direction
i'm now going to consider all of the
elements
of z that we're interested in right
now i don't have to do this for all of
them i don't have to write down every
element of z
that exists i just have to think about
can i take all these
infinite different possibilities and
break them down to a finite set of cases
so let's think about this right
i can say uh well let's start from
somewhere like negative three
negative two negative one zero one
two three let's go up
a little bit uh h should do it okay
so let's think about this how can i
break this into a set of cases
well remember what i'm trying to do is
i'm trying to get at divisibility
by three right so what i noticed first
is that a series of the numbers
a set of the numbers i should say that i
wrote down here in the elements of z
they're just divisible by three from the
outset right so for example i mean we
normally think of the first multiple of
three as
three so oops let's make that
see-through
ta-da so three is a multiple of three
and it's not the only one i have i've
got
six over here um zero strictly speaking
is also a multiple of three because it's
three times zero and then lastly because
we're including the integers here
negative three can also be classified as
a multiple or if it's divisible by
3. now here is one of my categories
right
i can say that a could be one of these
kinds of numbers but this doesn't
capture everything
so how do i capture additional ones well
i noticed that
i can also say a series or a set of
these
numbers a category is the ones that are
above those multiples of three just one
bigger
right you can see that a series of these
numbers can be written as not a multiple
of three but one more than a multiple of
three
and you can probably see where my logic
is now going to capture the entire
infinite list i can then say well if i
include also numbers
one less than a multiple of three i now
have oops there's eight as well
i have every single case covered right
so these numbers here
which are multiples of 3. i can write
them in the form 3
k yeah where k is my integer that i
introduced before
i can say that these numbers here
because they're all one more than a
multiple of three i can write them in
the form three k
plus one and then lastly to round it out
and make my list
exhaustive i can say that these numbers
here are one less
than a multiple of three so i write them
in the form three k
minus one here are my three cases
a has to be one of these right and if i
can prove
that you end up with a multiple of three
for a cubed minus
a regardless of which one of these three
you start with then
i'll be done okay so how do we go about
this let's consider
each of the cases so i will say
a can be written i'm just setting out my
cases here
a can be written as three k minus one
three k or three k
plus one right so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna say well
one at a time right if a equals
a three k minus 1 then
what can i say about a cubed minus a
well i can write it in that form that i
saw before which is the product of three
consecutive integers
so a minus 1 is going to look like 3 k
minus one minus one there's the first
one
then there's three k minus one in the
middle and then
three k minus one plus one okay just to
be really clear what am i doing here
there's my substitution once twice three
times into the form that i can write a n
that i know
i recognize all right i close that
bracket there
right so now what can i say well let's
just tidy this up right i've got three k
minus two
i've got three 3k minus 1. nothing needs
to be done to that and then on the end
here i've got 3
k well what this shows is i can
factorize
3 out of this and that means that the
whole thing
whatever comes after these brackets in
this case it's 3k minus 2
3k minus 1 and then just k whatever
comes in
here i'm going to multiply by 3 so i'm
divisible by 3.
okay great now i need to rinse and
repeat and just do it for the other
cases so
if alternatively a was not three k minus
one
it might be one of the three k's right
this one's even easier
i can just say a cubed minus a must
therefore b
um three k minus one three k
oops brackets going the wrong way and
three k plus one i don't even need to do
any tidying up here i just need to pull
out the relevant factor of three
and then write everything else
afterwards so that leaves me with a k
and then three k plus one and by now
you're like i can do this on autopilot
right my final case is the 3k
plus 1 case so i'm going to say for a
cubed minus
a when i do my substitution it's going
to give me take a breath
3 k plus 1 minus 1
3 k plus 1 and then 3 k plus one
plus one uh this will tidy up leaves
that three out the front
uh big brackets then there's the k the
plus one and minus one have cancelled
and then i get three k plus one three k
plus 2. so now just like before i have
looked at every possibility
for a and they all end up with a cubed
minus a being divisible by
3. you can see it here here and here
so like before i can say therefore for
all
the values of a that are integers a
cubed minus a
is divisible
[Music]
by three okay
happy times i'm on the home stretch now
so
i want to prove that this whole thing
the the divisibility that by two and the
divisible by three
will land me with divisibly by six now
you may be happy to accept that but we
can also prove it using
a fairly straightforward algebra right
any number
divisible by 6
can be written
as let's just say
6 k right
but 6k i can write that as a
factorization right i can say
well let's pull the 2 out it's 2 times
some number or alternatively i can
factorize out the 3 and say it's 3 times
some number so in other words n being
divisible by
6 means that i can write it as 6k
but you can see that
necessarily means it has to be divisible
by both two and three so this is an if
and only if
statement it's an equivalent statement
so n is divisible
by 2 and it's also divisible by 3 at the
same
time so this is it right i can say
since a cubed
minus a is divisible
by 2 and 3 which i've proven above by
exhaustion
what that means is it has to be
therefore
a cubed minus a has to be divisible
by 6 as well
as required now
let's just take a breath and review what
we've established right
when you have a look at a question like
this a cubed minus a is divisible by 6
for all integer values right you want to
break this down into some bite-sized
chunks because then you can take each
piece
and you can prove them one at a time and
then they come together
in this logical conclusion when you
combine everything
it is worth noting that in order to say
something and guarantee that it is true
sometimes you have to go through some
slightly laborious
uh algebra but i hope that you're
convinced that this way of doing it even
though
like i said i think it's probably about
the same number of lines of working as
proving this by induction
using two proofs by induction the line
of logic is much clearer we kind of knew
um even from this point here when we had
established that there was this
divisibility or sorry rather that
this there was this product of three
consecutive integers right once we got
there
we had the guts of the proof and we just
needed to go through each of the
components
so i hope you found that helpful make
sure you think about how you can break
things down in a reasonable way
and sometimes it helps to you know think
of some actual cases because often your
logic
that you'll use for all cases becomes
apparent when you do it for one or two
cases